[Musik]
wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns hier
in unserer kleinen süßen bei krefeld und
meine lieben freunde ich bin richtig gut
gelaunt denn in der heutigen episode
werden wir dir ich werde in der heutigen
episode mal wieder richtig obwohl mich
nur auf eine kleine sache konzentriert
da ich der einzige heute gut drauf ist
ich habe auf jeden fall ein krasses ziel
für die heutige episode und meine lieben
freunde das hat nur etwas mit unserer
trauer inseln hier hinten zu tun den esb
bisschen zu traurig ja das kann man
schon so sagen
und deswegen habe ich mich in den
kommentaren mal umgesehen ob mir jemand
eine idee hatte was wir daraus noch so
machen können da wurde mir das
geschrieben und campingplatz fand ich
gut die idee eine ganz kurze temmels wie
ich mir alle items dafür zusammen
sammeln
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe jetzt
acht minuten gebraucht um mit diese
ganzen items sie zusammen zu sammeln und
zusammen zu kräften und eventuell fragt
sich auch der ein oder andere buch du
hast doch hier vorne weg ist aber ganz
cool biz vorlesen lassen was haben
männer und waschmaschinen gemeinsam wenn
man sie an macht drehen sie durch
ich weiß dass wir hier vorne unseren
kleinen campingplatz haben wo wir auch
damals nur kleine schaukel noch am start
hatten die sache ist allerdings dass ich
mir gedacht habe hey hinten auf unserer
trauer insel wir haben da eine kirche
wir haben da alles ein bisschen düster
deswegen habe ich auch noch ein paar
mehr stein zu mauern und laternen
mitgenommen die wir in der letzten folge
getradet haben mit unserem villiger
deswegen fand ich den kommentar ganz
cool mit dem campingplatz da vorne hat
noch ein paar andere sachen uns
vorgeschlagenen wir machen könnten
und ich glaube auch nicht dass ich den
campingplatz dafür benutzen werde was
mit ein paar andere auch noch in die
kommentare geschrieben hatten und ihm
recht gegeben haben von wegen henning
kommt man ja super nutzen um irgendwie
story zu erzählen oder so die sonne geht
unter das heißt es ganz kurz eben
schlafen
das werde ich glaube ich nicht machen
weil ich immer so viel auf meiner to do
liste habe dass wir gar nicht die zeit
dafür haben dass ich irgendwie wollte
könnte ich aber echt mal ganz kurz hallo
so geht das nicht
warum kann ich von dir keine rolle
nehmen was ich mir auf jeden fall
gedacht hatte war dass wir den weg hier
vorne weiterlaufen lassen in diese
richtung und dann hier quasi unser lager
alb folgen habe ich sogar wirklich dass
nämlich auch das ding ich hab mal ganz
viel weit so noch samen mitgebracht dann
kann ich die ski gut abtropfen vergessen
ja du kriegst auch ein bisschen weit du
kriegst fast letztlich wo wir die andere
haben dann können wir die auch mal ein
bisschen vermehren hier wiederum läuft
die hinten endlich mal noch eine rum da
vorne läuft noch einen allerdings haben
wir hier auch noch ein schwein also ich
habe auf jeden fall sachen mitgenommen
dass wenn ich ihre seele dass ich die
auch ein bisschen füttern kann hier noch
eine zweite kundig und nicht so ihr
beiden könnten kleine baby co bekommt
und für dich habe ich sogar ein paar
weizenkörner mit am start und die frage
ist jetzt so wie das andere ist das hier
ist eine margerite ist die kamera also
schwer sondern erhalten hier soll dann
noch ein hühnchen ich habe auch schon
überlegt bei ein huhn mit rüber zu
nehmen hinten mit auf unsere insel so
dass wir dann so ein kleines boom bei
uns auf der insel haben mit dem dann
auch mal ein bisschen quatschen können
allerdings ist dass ich das thema für
heute denn wir müssen hier vorne erst
mal den ganzen das ganze unkraut ihr weg
machen sage ich mal das soll nämlich
jede so alles vonstatten gehen und was
ich mir auch gedacht dass das irgendwie
mal kurz aus der hand nehmen was ich mir
auf jeden fall auf gedacht hatte war das
ganze hier so ein bisschen abschneiden
lassen damit wir einfach so ein bisschen
mehr platz haben für den ganzen apparat
und damit das hier nicht so komisch
aussieht hatte ich mir auch extra
hierfür einige wie ich heiß der apparat
eichenstämme mitgenommen damit ich den
hier so direkt runter setzen kann denn
hier vorne kommt jetzt auch endlich
wieder unsere schaufel dran schaukel
kommt daran darf habe ich nämlich extra
die ketten mitgenommen und auch extra
einige wo habe ich
die nicht mitgenommen ich muss nicht
mitgenommen da sind sie ich habe doch
gar nicht oder ist auch egal auf jeden
fall habe ich viele kommentare gewinnen
von wegen luca wann kommt denken sie
schaukelt zurück die habe ich ja schon
lange tafel habe ich das schon lange auf
meiner to do liste stehen
von daher können wir jetzt endlich mal
das ganze ding fertig machen und die
kommt nämlich hier so hin
das ist der anfang von unserem
campingplatz dann habe ich mir gedacht
wenn jemand auf der schaukel sitzt kann
ihn ja jemand gegenüber sitzen zum
beispiel irgendwie mache hier würde ich
sagen einfach oder
dann könnten die beiden sich irgendwie
unterhalten er kann seine beinchen hier
drauflegen und das machen wir nicht so
wir machen das anders wir bauen das ding
hier wieder abgebaut
das ding hier ab und wir machen das
ganze so in die richtung und das machen
wir auch nicht wieder super vorbereitet
ich hab das alles vorgebaut in meiner
test welt allerdings habe ich mir dann
gedacht mensch ich will das ganze
einfach irgendwie ein bisschen hier
entscheiden die das hier am besten in
naturalien passt also die beiden können
ja hier liegen wie so sitzen und sich
dann irgendwie angucken das passt auch
nicht so richtig weiß ich was auf jeden
fall erstmal weg muss sind diese ganzen
blätter hier so ich habe den ganzen baum
hier ab gefällt denn nach vorne kommt
dann umsatz hält hin ich habe mir
wirklich auch ein richtiges campingzelt
rausgesucht wasser bauen möchte um
zunächst brauchen wir hier vorne
allerdings den weg so ein bisschen
weiter so dass ich genau weiß wie ich
das hier alles anordnen will denn ich
möchte dass wir hier vorne um uns einen
kleinen weg hierdurch bauen können dann
nehme ich hier den mohn weg und die
margherita und dann können wir uns hier
quasi zu dem pool hinstellen mit
ziemlich unserem natürlichen see es ist
ja kein puls und den möchte ich auch ein
ganzes stockwerk tiefer erheben weil ich
mir gedacht hat dann sieht das ganze ein
bisschen mehr nach tiefer aus so sieht
der see auf jeden fall schon mal
deutlich nach außen dann können wir uns
theoretisch hier hinstellen und ein
bisschen
ich werde auch hier vorne jetzt mal so
eine laterne hinsetzen dann haben wir
hier unseren kleinen ausgang sage ich
mal aus dem see raus und ich kann doch
eigentlich mal hierhin noch mehr
hinsetzen hier freunde in die ecke
vielleicht hier vorne noch eine und auch
hier und hier die hier vorne wollte ich
allerdings eigentlich gerade in die ecke
setzen also die man immer ganz kurz
wieder abbauen und hierhin dann haben
nämlich den ganzen see hier auch so ein
bisschen beleuchtung das sieht anders
aus
vielleicht können wir den see hier
irgendwann auch mal unter wasser so
gestalten wie auf unserer insel da
hinten allerdings kommt hier jetzt auch
natürlich erst mal so ein bisschen hier
schonmal lagerfeuer feeling haben und
kämpfer mäßig ein lagerfeuer hin hier
vorne neben das lagerfeuer möchte ich
der kleine bank setzen und zwar aus
eichenstämmen die soll auch die sollen
nämlich hier so hinkommen 1234 so
allerdings müssen wir denen jedoch noch
mal ganz kurz umdrehen und das sieht
jetzt zwar nicht so gut aus weil hier
vorne die blätter draußen allerdings
finde ich das gibt dem ganzen so ein
bisschen lockt platzieren wir vorne
beispielsweise noch eine laterne hin
dann habe ich auch einen blumentopf
mitgenommen wie man dann zum beispiel
hier vor setzen kann das ist dann so
eine art ja futternapf oder so falls man
ein hund hier mit dabei hat dann habe
ich auch noch anstatt neben ich habe
nicht nur normale räder mitgenommen
sondern auch noch grobe erde denn ich
habe auch toten busch mitgenommen denn
den finde ich kann man auch mal ganz gut
platzieren
und wenn ich normale erde nehmen würde
und dann wird der tote busch innerhalb
von kürzester zeit wenn das darunter zu
groß werden würde einfach verschwinden
deswegen musste ich die grobe erde
mitnehmen einen anderen toten busch
können wir beispielsweise vielleicht
noch nie vorne irgendwie dran setzen
oder so gesagt allerdings kommen wir nun
endlich zu dem worauf ich glaube ich
gewartet habe habe ich mir hier nicht
wieder anhand eines tutorials orientiert
das habe ich euch selbstverständlich und
in der beschreibung eingeblendet und
zwar das hält dann müssen wir erstmal
hier vorne eine eins zwei drei vier fünf
große fläche machen
allerdings ist die gans oder sieben lang
genau in diese richtung hier noch zack
zack das hier wird nämlich quasi unser
zelteingang da müssen wir dann einen
fichtenholz zaun hoch setzen zack zack
und das wird falsch sondern noch einen
obendrauf nämlich zack und daran machen
die es auf beiden seiten unser zelt
quasi fest für das zelt habe ich mich
bei dem zelt habe ich mich für wolle
entschieden
finde ich glaube ich ganz nice wenn man
das in der konstellation macht und zwar
einfach 1 2 3 4 5 auf der seite und dann
noch 5 auf der anderen seite es gibt
leider kein material was ein bisschen
dünner ist sage ich mal als die wolle
es wird ein sehr dickes setzen danke für
deine meinung hier fordert drauf
platzieren auf jeden fall nochmal drei
wolle blöcke daran ist schon unser
geschäft darin stehen jeden schuss mehr
um den kopf hier vorne platzieren wir
natürlich auch nummer drei blöcke und
dann müssen wir jetzt hier so übergangs
blöcke hinsetzen die wir gleich
allerdings abbauen werden
und genau das gleiche nochmal auf der
anderen seite generell wird es so sein
dass wir auf beiden seiten das zelt
eigentlich identisch bauen so dass wir
von beiden seiten noch
selbstverständlich reingehen können die
frage ich jetzt auch wahrscheinlich dass
hatten das geld eigentlich für nutzen da
kommt nämlich auch eine menge utensilien
rein zb eine menge fest dann müssen wir
nämlich hier die seiten auch nochmal
komplett entfernen 123 47 12 45 397 so
hier kommen nämlich eine menge fässer
rein sagt zack zack zack zack zack und
da in die mitte habe ich mir gedacht
eine werkbank und auf der anderen seite
vor unser zelt da habe ich mir gedacht
um das ganze hier auch auf die seite ein
bisschen cooler zu packen
packen wir drei höfen und dann noch
einen räucherofen einen schmelzofen
räucherofen schmelzofen und in die ecken
an nummer zwölf fässer hat sagt und zack
dann haben wir hier auf jeden fall
ordentlich stauraum für alle möglichen
sachen ich weiß zwar noch nicht für was
aber vielleicht fällt ja mal irgendwas
noch ein für diese insel hier wir haben
ja noch eine menge platz vielleicht
würden brunnen noch einen neuen oder
eine neue fahne oder irgendwas mit honig
da kenne ich mich doch überhaupt nicht
mit aus allerdings ist meine lieben
freunde müssen wir nun erstmal mit den
pflichten holztreppen so ein bisschen
arbeiten und zwar kommt hier vorne eine
fichtenholz treppe drauf
und auch auf der anderen seite auf unser
fass und dann hier sonne gedreht der
fichten holztreppe also einmal beim und
haben das gleiche wiederholt auch für
die andere seite seht ihr auch schon wie
wir in unser zelt reinkommen und zwar
müssen wir uns wirklich dicken also
quasi shift gedrückt halten um in unser
zelt reinzukommen und das finde ich
eigentlich ganz neues weil wenn man in
sein eigentliches zelt beim campen gehen
will muss man sich auch mal ducken also
in fünf zum beispiel hier wenn ich dir
so normal gegen laufe komme ich nicht
rein
ich muss mich weg nicht wirken und dann
vorgehen und dann bin ich drin
also es ist wirklich ganz geil finde ich
der boden hier ist ein bisschen aus erde
ein bisschen aus gras zerstört nicht
gerade noch ein bisschen denn ich möchte
ich eigentlich komplett gras haben um
dann nachher aus dem gras eventuell ein
paar ecken so ein bisschen wege zu
machen jetzt muss ich allerdings auch
shift drücken um hier raus zu kommen so
und dafür habe ich auch extra meine gold
spitzhacke mitgenommen mit behutsamkeit
von daher können wir uns jetzt hier
vorne einfach mal fertige gras blöcken
nehmen und die dann quasi ersetzen durch
normale ehrt blöcke wieder rede ich ein
klatschen am stück ich glaube ich auch
gar kein makel hintergrund was so lange
läuft ich bin einfach hat volle meinem
element ich liebe bauen um minecraft
einfach komplett von daher würde ich
sagen dass wir uns auch gar nicht lange
ablenken ich habe es natürlich
selbstverständlich das bettchen
vergessen ist allerdings auch egal dass
können wir nämlich ganz kurz kräften
dafür haben wir nämlich ein bisschen
holz mitgenommen und ich habe extra ein
bisschen mehr wolle mitgenommen also
einmal ganz kurz das bettchen nehmen
hierhin platzieren dann kann man auch
schon direkt eine runde schlafen gehen
in unserem zelt ist nicht fertig also
jetzt nicht irgendwie den tag irgendwie
vom abend loben hier
ich möchte erstmal hier vorne noch so
ein bisschen gras zehn platzieren hier
filme noch 123456 gras blöcke die hole
ich mir jetzt einfach mal hier vorne
das ist ja unser zelt platz dann gehe
ich einfach mal hierhin 1 2 3 4 5 und 6
die ersetzen wir natürlich
selbstverständlich wie das ist echt
geisteskrank wie schnell diese
spitzhacke kaputtgeht sie es einfach
jetzt schon halb kaputt ich habe
insgesamt vielleicht zwölf blöcke
abgebaut oder so aber diese sechs blöcke
benötigen wir auf jeden fall ich werde
die zwei gleich direkt wieder weg machen
und andererseits durch grobe erde und
durch wege ersetzen jetzt habe ich eine
kuh drin ist rekord hätte am rad raus
mit dir halt schön so jetzt haben wir
komplett gras jetzt werde ich das hier
so ein bisschen aufteilen und zwar hier
zum beispiel grobe erde hin hier eine
grobe erde hin dann machen wir hier noch
eine gruppe er drin und da wo die kuh
draufsteht dankeschöns alle sehr
kooperativ irgendwie heute jetzt habe
ich allerdings auch noch eine schaufel
und da können wir hier einen weg machen
hier einen weg hier einen weg dann
vielleicht auch hier einen weg den weg
hier einen weg hier hier hier und
vielleicht auch hier dass der mond so
jetzt ist unsere schafft auch kaputt
dankeschön und jetzt kümmern wir uns das
von innen jetzt quasi alles fertig ist
unser ziel ist es gar nicht
ich habe mir extra mir noch den
entwendeten dings gemacht und die
laterne sieht mich sehr geil aus wenn
man das hier einfach so hin platziert
dann ist unser feldbett wenn ich jetzt
einfach mal hier vorne sollen hier vorne
so ein bisschen abgegrenzt und zombies
und so kommen nicht rein weil die können
sich ja nicht ducken creeper kommen
nicht rein
wir sind allerdings drin die sache ist
dass wir uns jetzt erstmal auf das dach
konzentrieren müssen
da machen wir nämlich 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4
5 und jetzt setzen wir hier vorne auch
wieder unsere treppen darauf nämlich
eine pflichten holztreppe so hier eine
pflichten holztreppe
so richtig es ist richtig und hier
fordere auch noch meine pflicht neue
tresor und eine fischtreppe so ihr oben
drauf kommt jetzt eine fichtenholz stufe
auf beide seiten
und hier kommt auch noch mal weiße wolle
hätte ich habe jetzt eine weiße wolle zu
wenig dafür haben wir allerdings
natürlich überall scharf ich weiß nicht
wo das eine schafft gerade war hier
vorne ist es perfekt dass der
bürgermeister nicht der bürgermeister
kann aber direkt nochmal sternen also
hier oben kommt auf jeden fall auch noch
volle drauf und dann können wir
ich glaube so ein kleines kreuz drauf
setzen dafür benötige ich allerdings
noch mehr wolle ich weiß nicht ob das
schäfchen hier vorne schon wieder neue
rolle hat ich glaube nicht dass er
gerade erst geschert ist es denn hier
vorne das ist noch relativ naked haben
wir irgendwo da noch weitere schaaf wir
hätten noch auf jeden fall ein paar mehr
hier werden auch noch den bürgermeister
irgendwo den will ich eigentlich nicht
scheren das ist auch nicht der
bürgermeister allerdings weiß ja gar
nicht wo der cut ist liegt er überhaupt
noch wir haben hier auch teilweise schon
einige tote beklagen müssen von tieren
wo wir gar nicht irgendwie mit
eingegriffen sind sondern die wirklich
einfach ins lagerfeuer gerannt sind oder
irgendwo vor dem baum der gerade
gewachsen ist dann irgendwie erschlagen
wurden falls man überhaupt so nennen
kann
wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch ein
schäfchen und clement sprechen ein
bisschen wolle hier vorne war einst das
noch immer nackt der hier vorne schon
wieder wolle bekomme ich glaube auch
nicht weiß noch gar nicht wo der kleine
ist dann machen wir das mit der wolle
auf jeden fall gleich dachte jetzt dass
es relativ fix geht allerdings brauchen
wir noch zwei wollen wir können
allerdings auch uns jetzt gas machen die
fichten kümmern da hab ich mir nicht
gedacht dass man sich die hierhin packt
und hier und auch hier vorne und dann
wir unter denen ganz kurz ab um hier mal
hinzusetzen und das gleiche da holen wir
jetzt auch noch hundertmal natürlich
auch auf der anderen seite hier und hier
und auch hier vorne und hier fordert
dann haben wir quasi auf der seite ihren
coolen eingang und auch auf der anderen
seite ihnen die haben wir voll viele
schweine auf unserer tier insel aber
fast keine schafe nämlich eigentlich
auch noch ein kleines baby bekommen ach
guck mal hier bitte zwei perfekt drei
wolle haben wir sogar bekommen also
können wir jetzt entspannt hier und hier
noch wolle hinsetzen und hier oben drauf
kommen jetzt auch noch fichtenholz wald
innen und außen herum kommen nun auch
noch zwei
da ihren sohn prinz und darin sonnen und
da und das wahre lieben freunde war
tatsächlich auch schon unser campfire
also wir sind noch nicht ganz fertig mit
unserem dings hier
denn was ich mir auch noch überlegt
hatte wir sind fertig wir sind fertig
das ging ja deutlich schneller als
gedacht hatte dass die männer lieben
freunde ist unser neue campingplatz wir
haben hier vorne unser lagerfeuer wir
haben hier einen kleinen weg durch die
natur hin zu unserem sie wo wir uns an
unsere angenehmen können die ich gerade
nicht dabei habe und ein bisschen
angehen gehen können ich werde auch mal
ganz kurz die ganzen bohnen die ich hier
von abgebaut habe mal wieder hier
hinsetzen drumherum mit das alles hier
nochmal ein bisschen schöner aussieht
hier vorne noch eine hinzu
hier sitzt mal den sternlauf hin und
hier noch eine margarete ich dachte
ehrlich gesagt dass es deutlich länger
dauert allerdings ist es natürlich
dadurch dass ich das immer an meiner
testfeld schon vorbei sei sie für mich
das ganze danach zu bauen
hier vorne es auf jeden fall unser zelt
da können wir uns entspannt rheins
nieten haben unser web wir haben eine
werkbank wir haben genügend situationen
um ihnen die sachen zu lagern wir können
sachen beraten
wir haben hier ein hühnchen was ich
jetzt glaube ich sogar mal mit dem
werden alle mitnehmen werder zu unserer
insel
da hab ich nämlich auf jeden fall bock
drauf so dass münchen kommt man mal kurz
mit und sonst haben wir vorne die
schaukel also zwei sitzmöglichkeiten der
toten busch wir haben hier sollen
stammen
neben den blumentopf also ich freue mich
auf jeden fall wir haben das camping
dinge auf jeden fall die hatte ich
gekriegt und ich bin gerade mal bei 40
minuten
das war eine viel zu produktiv norden
ein
jetzt haben wir hier double trouble ja
gerne nur eine person von euch beiden so
perfekt wir haben es wirklich geschafft
innerhalb von dreißig vierzig minuten
lässt sich das video gerade geht
wahrscheinlich so 15 minuten oder so
alles fertig zu kriegen was ich mir
erhofft habe fürs heutige video ich
werde einmal ganz kurz hier vorne links
halten mit unserem hühnchen damit ist
hier entspannt rausholen kann damit es
direkt an land gehen kann also einmal
ganz schnell das boot hier abbauen und
das hühnchen kann zurück auf unsere
insel kommen bzw
das heißt zurück auf unsere insel da und
dann zombie ja meine lieben freunde das
hühnchen ist zurück auf unserer insel
bzw kommt es an land oder es ist zu dumm
in einer anscheinend bist du eher dumm
wenn es nicht mehr schafft du kannst
auch an land vor mir weglaufen
ok entspannt wir haben wir ham das sehe
ich ja aber da muss ich auch schon nicht
warum das da war ich kann dir auf jeden
fall dem login vorne abbauen aber ich
weiß nicht warum das jeden angeht warum
hilft das denn jedem weiter dass er dann
über den blog daneben die raus jetzt ist
wieder drin
haye ist mir jetzt auch mittlerweile
scheißegal meine lieben freunde wir
hatten heute zwangsläufig fast der
komplette uncut folge finde ich krass
ich hätte ihn wirklich nicht gedacht
dass ich das so gut hinkriege ich bin
selber von mir selbst überrascht gerade
ich so thema ganz kurz noch meine items
sie eben wieder rein hier kommt alles
rein was aus holz ist also dass hier das
fichtenholz platziere ich gleich dass
man da hinten du kommst da rein
hier vorne kommt noch die erde hin die
wolle packen wir doch die vornherein die
steinmauern eigentlich wollte ich noch
ein paar mehr
steinmauern setzen mit fackeln drauf
allerdings habe ich mir dann irgendwann
auch gedacht mensch ich habe da so viel
licht mittlerweile brauche ich nicht
unbedingt weizen kommt in die andere
kiste die teile kommen hier rheingold
spitzhacke brauche ich gerade nicht was
ich allerdings benötige sind auf jeden
fall meine freunde die ich schon im
inventar habe das kommt auf die so so
ich brauche auf jeden fall auch noch
eine neue schaufel die ich mir mal eben
kurz machen kann
denn meine lieben freunde ich muss mich
auch schon so ein bisschen ausrüsten
fürs nächste video wo ich mal wieder ein
oder andere wird es wahrscheinlich ein
kollaps bekommen aber ich möchte mal
wieder in den äther gehen weil ich habe
mir das mal ausgerechnet vor der folge
ich benötige nötige einfach 400 klocke
ich weiß nicht warum ich mir gedacht
habe hey luca die ganzen sechs die ich
habe die sollten schon ausreichen
allerdings reicht es nicht aus das hab
ich mir dann gedacht habe mensch kommen
dann jemanden episode noch mal so ein
bisschen farmen und was wir in der
nächsten folge auch machen werden und da
hoffe ich dass unser schäfchen hier
wieder braune wolle hat perfekt sogar
zwei stück super wir haben
nämlich für die nächste folge zwei es
auf unserer liste also jetzt schon auf
unserer liste ohne dass ich eure
kommentare bisher sogar gesehen habe und
es waren wir 30 pro voll und wir
brauchen genau 30 braune wolle für
unseren kopf von der kuh
deswegen ist das todo für die nächste
folge auf jeden fall dass wir einerseits
in den neckar gehen und uns eine menge
lediglich eine menge quarzwerke holen
und auf der anderen seite uns auch
endlich um den kühkopf kümmern
der dort vorne ja dann stehen soll also
wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollte
freunde dann schaltet auf jeden fall in
der nächsten episode mohrrübe morgen um
20 uhr wieder ein wenn es wieder heißt
minecraft mit luca und diese idioten
plantschen am jetzt zusammen natürlich
gefallen hat was gerne daumen hoch unter
video er da abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die locke ist doch kein teil
der look für seit ich auch nicht
[Musik]